And I would say the answers are comparing auto repair rates.
Those are simply proportions that can be compared to each other
as we've done for many things.
And determining if a course improve test scores.
We would argue that we can't compare crash rates of two airlines with 100 flights
because in general there aren't crashes.
Now in theory, you could say you can use a hypothesis test
if you recognize that it's not normally distributed and do the appropriate
binomial test and figure out that you can't determine anything
but it's generally not adding anything over intuition.
And comparing heights of the tallest building in two cities, that's a deterministic number.
It's either their taller or it's not. There are no random errors. There's no need for a hypothesis test.
That again a more creative application could be that you'd want to use it to
the measurements of the buildings in each of the two cities to determine whether
one was taller but that's only going to be useful if the measurements have the error
on the same order of the difference in buildings which is unusual.
So in practice you would not use a hypothesis test there.